I think conservatives bear a little bit
of responsibility for all of this you
know conservatives very often will say
I've been guilty of it myself in the
past I'll say things like we want to
educate
indoctrinate children in fact those
words mean exactly the same thing right
you know we want to teach children how
to think not what to think as if you can
know how to think without knowing what
to think about certain things you can't
know how to think about abstract
mathematics if you don't know that two
plus two equals four you need to know
that the American Revolution started in
1776 in order to think about history you
need to know certain things and there's
this real irony that that conservatives
have adopted this idea of and really
embrace the idea of academic freedom to
this radical extreme that teachers can
teach radical racial theories radical
sexual theories the conservative
movement began when William F Buckley Jr
wrote a book called guided man at Yale
making fun of this perversion of
academic freedom